madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal à seattle situation de crise à
quelques heures de la clôture de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
difficiles négociations de nombreuses
divergences entre l'union européenne la
france et les états unis
coup d'envoi du xiiie téléthon baptisé
téléthon 2030 heures de direct sur notre
chaîne lionel jospin ce matin annoncé
que la france allait donner plus d'un
milliard de francs supplémentaires sur
cinq en suspens dans l'espace avec
l'atterrissage sur mars de la sonde
américaine dans les instants qui
viennent objectif de cette mission
trouver de l'eau sur la planète rouge
la belgique s'apprête à célébrer le
dernier mariage du siècle mathilde
épousera de mal le prince héritier
philippe de quoi redonner des couleurs à
un pays en crise
et puis la coupe davis finale à nice
depuis cet après midi mark philippoussis
sa offert le premier point le stralis
cédric pioline vient de gagner face à
lleyton hewitt et et permet à la france
d'égaliser à seattle journée cruciale
une journée qui risque d'être bien
longue pour les négociateurs qui vont
tenter de trouver d'ici ce soir coûte
que coûte un semblant d'accord on semble
loin du compte
les déclarations se sont multipliées ces
dernières heures jacques chirac qui
affirme que la france et l'union
européenne ne transigerons pas nous y
reviendrons dans un instant mais d'abord
le point sur cette situation de crise où
subsistent des divergences importantes
entre l'europe et les états unis
pascal golomer de vie et gosnay
il a négocié toute la nuit multiplier
les rencontres avec les américains
notamment pour tenter de rédiger un
texte à la fois consensuelle et fidèle à
l'idée européenne d'un agenda élargi
mais pascal lamy n'a pas pu annoncer le
moindre accord ce matin il continue donc
de négocier avec réalisme mais on
n'arrive jamais à la fin d'une
négociation exactement là où vous voulez
partir et je ne suis pas le seul à
vouloir un texte ambitieux et qui
adresse numéros sujet discrètement en
effet dans ces salles de réunions à
l'abri des caméras les européens tentent
de convaincre les pays en développement
de soutenir leurs propositions à propos
des normes sociales et environnementales
à propos de l'ouverture des marchés
aussi encore faut-il déjà débloqué le
dossier agricole
l'europe ne veut plus entendre parler de
la notion d'élimination même progressive
des subventions à l'exportation les
américains les australiens les argentins
eux n'en démordent pas la france est un
grand pays exportateur de produits
agricoles alimentaires remettre en cause
aujourd'hui les aides à l'exportation
serait un coup fatal pour notre économie
française voire européenne vous entre
deux réunions
le secrétaire d'état français au
commerce extérieur est simplement venue
il ya quelques minutes rappeler la
fermeté des européens sur ce sujet comme
sur les autres je ne sais pas si nous
arriverons à un accord ou si il n'y aura
pas de lancement de sixx que je peux
simplement vous confirmer c'est que nous
sommes nous français parfaitement au
clair sur les conditions que nous
mettons au lancement d'un cycle
il ne reste plus que quelques heures aux
négociateurs pour débloquer la situation
personne ni côté européen ni côté
américain ne semble vouloir de toute
façon aller au delà de l'échéance prévue
et le président de la république a
commenté de la réunion lors d'une
conférence de presse les dernières
transactions autour d'un accord possible
à seattle déclarations ouvertement
pessimiste pour jacques chirac la
négociation se déroule dans une certaine
confusion
le chef de l'état qui a montré une
opposition catégorique à toute
élimination des aides européennes à
l'exportation des produits agricoles
je propose est écouté nous accepterons
par conséquent en aucun cas un texte qui
je le répète par étaient deux circule
mais je ne sais pas du tout qu'elle est
dans l'état actuel des choses sa valeur
mais qui prévoirait l'élimination
progressive des aides à l'exportation
des aides européennes à l'exportation
des produits agricoles est tout à fait
exclu que nous acceptions cette affaire
nous serons très vigilants et ne qu'on
ne compte pas sur la france pour faire
preuve dans ce domaine de la moindre
faiblesse alors nous verrons où tout
ceci va nous conduire nous le serons
dans les 24 heures qui viennent
mais pour le moment je suis pas très
optimiste sur ses résultats ce qui est
je le répète certain c'est que la france
et l'europe et l'union européenne ne
transigerons pas sur les principes qui
fondent le mandat qui a été donné à
notre commissaire et nous rejoignons en
direct de seattle pascal golomer on le
comprend bien les négociations semblent
se tendre à quelques heures de la fin du
sommet quelles sont les chances de voir
un accord à votre avis
plutôt béatrice derrière les
déclarations diplomatiques officielles
les commentaires ce matin à seattle sont
pessimistes quant à l'issue de cette
négociation en négociation qui doit se
terminer en principe ce soir à 18 heures
tant les positions des uns et des autres
sont éloignés position en ligne et
notamment entre les européens et les
américains à propos du dossier agricole
nous l'avons dit il ya quelques quelques
minutes les européens 10 pays sur 15 se
prononcer contre la dernière proposition
qui était fait et puis position est
venue également entre les pays
développés et les pays en développement
des pays en développement qui ont très
mal pris la proposition des pays riches
de parler de normes sociales au sein de
le nc des pays en développement
également qu'ils se sentent marginalisés
au sein de cette négociation très
critique et d'ailleurs y compris du côté
européen 53 pays africains mené à cette
fière de ne pas signer l'accord quel
qu'il soit en signe de protestation
au fond la question essentielle est de
savoir à qui profiterait cet accord et
s'ils y accord est ce qu'on pourra dire
en un mot que c'est un accord de dupes
en fait dès le début de la conférence
les européens et les français d'être à
siens dans cette question avait dit il
n'est pas question de signer un accord
au rabais un accord qu'ils ne
reprendraient pas l'idée d'élargissement
aux autres sujets nous l'avons
évoquer déjà à propos des normes
sociales et environnementales notamment
les américains eux souhaitaient se
limiter aux questions agricoles aux
questions des services il est certain
que si aucun accord n'était trouvé sur
l'agriculture et si les américains
refusent d'avoir un agenda élargi il ya
peu de chances qu'on parvienne à un
accord ce soir
merci pascal de la mer l'actualité en
france quinze ans après le début de
l'affairé grégory les avocates des
grands parents de l'enfant assassiné ont
l'intention de demander un complément
d'enquêté avec l'utilisation de tests
adn sur les timbres poste des lettres du
corbeau dont l'une revendiquer
clairement le meurtre de grégory
l'utilisation de ces nouvelles
techniques ultra sophistiqué si elle est
acceptée par le juge cette utilisation
pose un certain nombre de questions
tirées kurt et la vérité de la sphère
grigori se cache peut être derrière ce
timbre cette lettre menaçante envoyé au
grand père de l'enfant porte l'identité
du corbeau dans l'adn de la salive qui
en coller le petit carré de papier pour
les scientifiques les obstacles à
l'identification ne sont pas
insurmontables 17 ans mais il y a tout
de même certaines conditions nous avons
du recul avec des échantillons qui sont
différents qui avait plusieurs années
près de dix ans et qui nous en donner
son permis d'avoir des résultats avec
succès mais nous avons déjà travaillé
sur des échantillons
- âgées pour lesquelles nous n'avons pas
pu obtenir de résultats certains membres
de la famille avait gardé enfoui au fond
de leur mémoire cette pièce à conviction
c'est une affaire marseillaise du même
type résolu grâce à une analyse de
salive 14 ans après qui a fait renaître
le fol espoir
cette décision est une décision
réfléchie
il est dirigé contre personne ne
voudrait pas qu'il y ait la moindre
équivoque là dessus nous sommes au
service de la vérité
et tant qu'il restera un espoir de voir
confondre à travers le corbeau
l'assassin biétry grégory serait
criminel de ne pas intenter pour
christine et jean marie villemin coupé
aujourd'hui du reste de leur famille
c'est une nouvelle épreuve
ils redoutent par dessus tout le réveil
des passions et des haines suscité par
la faire et ne veulent surtout pas de
nouvelles polémiques mais leurs avocats
la firme ils vont la certitude
scientifique que les résultats seront
indiscutable alors que tout bête on ose
analyse tout à fait d'accord et toutes
les mesures permettant d'avancer sur le
chemin de la vérité
plusieurs christian première question
faisabilité de l' expertise adn est ce
que nous avons le support est ce que les
scellés sont encore en bon état un
scientifique pourra répondre à ses
questions et nous le dira
les époux bill m'impose une autre
condition que les tests concernent tous
les protagonistes de la faire même si
aujourd'hui décédé les deux parties ont
fait la même demande auprès de la cour
d'appel de dijon
c'est donc elle qui décidera ou non de
la réouverture du dossier
à monaco la mort de l'un des hommes les
plus riches du monde d'après une
agression le milliardaire libanais omdh
influence sur la scène internationale
edmond safra patron d'une banque new
yorkaise ancien pdg d'american express
est décédé dans des conditions très
suspectes lors de l'incendié de son
appartement dans la principauté
une enquête pour homicide volontaire a
été ouverte yasmina farber le b l'époque
l'un de ces immeubles clinquant de la
principauté
c'est ici au petit matin pour le feu se
déclenche au dernier étage à l'extérieur
d'un appartement un incendie qui va se
révéler criminelle
un peu plus tôt deux hommes entrent dans
cet immeuble sous haute surveillance
ils agressent le gardien d'un coup de
couteau puis se dirige vers le domicile
du banquier libanais edmond safra l'un
des hommes les plus riches du monde
le financier se cache dans une salle de
bain avec une employée de maison
les agresseurs déclenché le système de
sécurité leurs victimes meurent
asphyxiés prise au piège
le banquier de 67 ans avait plusieurs
domiciles mais il privilégier sa
résidence monégasque et une villa à
villefranche sur mer présenté comme
l'homme mystérieux de la finance
il craignait pour sa vie ils étaient
protégés bien sûr et qu'il avait
toujours peur un petit peu de ce d'être
traqué un peu cédé ça y est l empire
comme il a construit en 50 ans bien sûr
ne fait que naître des jalousies les
milieux financiers de londres confirme
les menaces d'un contrat évoque même la
piste de la mafia russe
edmond safra était en train de réaliser
une énorme opération financière en
cédant deux de ses banques un groupe
britannique
le procureur général monégasque a ouvert
une information judiciaire pour
tentative d'assassinât et incendie
volontaire
à monaco le pays des banquiers de la
sécurité l'affairé bien sûr prise très
au sérieux au chapitre judiciaire les
réquisitions devant le tribunal
correctionnel de paris tout à l'heure
contre jean christophe cambadélis le
numéro deux du parti socialiste
huit mois 1 an de prison avec sursis et
500 mille francs d'amendé
jean christophe cambadélis les soupçonné
d'avoir occupé un emploi fictif de 93 à
et puis à toulon un an de prison et un
mandat d'arrêt requis contre jacques
crozemarie pour fraude fiscale
le jugement sera rendu contre l'ancien
patron de l'arc le 31 janvier prochain
dernier jour de campagne avant
l'élection du nouveau président du rpr
c'est demain que les militants vont à se
prononcer michèle alliot-marie bien
placé au premier tour et avec le
ralliement de françois fillon et patrick
devedjian michèle alliot marie a mené
une campagne tambour battant ne change
rien à son discours
pour sa part jean paul delevoye qui a
reçu le soutien de renaud muselier tente
de croire que tout est encore possible y
compris sa victoire carole comment
tenter de renverser l'arithmétique
voilà l'objectif de jean paul delevoye
celui qu'on présente comme le candidat
officiel de l'elysée est certes arrivé
en tête au premier tour avec 35% des
voix mais le score a déçu ses partisans
pour son dernier meeting parisien
il a donc choisi la manière forte pas de
dialogue intimiste mais un discours
offensif et quelques attaques contre les
battus du premier tour qui ont rejoint
son adversaire
les convictions de circonstance les
rafistolages de courant les
cohabitations contre nature se termine
inévitablement dans la guérilla interne
et dans le ridicule
les français ne veulent plus d'hommes de
politique de séduction
ils veulent des hommes politiques de
conviction pas de petites phrases
assassines
c'est la règle que s'est fixé et michèle
alliot-marie rassembler et réconcilier
le rpr son projet a séduit les militants
mais aussi françois fillon et patrick
devedjian rassembler un credo qu'elle
aura martelé jusqu'au dernier jour de la
campagne il y a de quoi faire pour tout
le monde
il y a de quoi faire pour toutes les
équipes nous constituerons et cela j'ai
envie de le faire avec vous rassemblons
nous réconcilions nous gardons l'unité
de notre mouvement c'est notre force
dont michèle alliot marie elle a choisi
de ne rien changer à son style de
campagne qui se veut proche des
militants elle dispose d'un autre atout
une femme à la tête du rpr apparaîtrait
sans aucun doute comme un signe de
renouvellement
nouveau record à la baisse de l'euro qui
est tombé cette nuit à son plus bas
niveau sous le seuil psychologique de 1
dollar pour un euro
même si l'euro est remonté légèrement
depuis la devise européenne a perdu 15%
de sa valeur depuis sa création en
janvier
et puis à la bourse 30e record pour le
cac 40 depuis le début de l'année qui
atteint à la clôture aujourd'hui 5468
point souhaite une augmentation de plus
de 2% par rapport à hier en bretagne une
nouvelle action des agriculteurs qui
réclament des mesures concrètes et
rapides pour sortir au plus vite des
situation de désespérance
un tiers des éleveurs seraient au bord
du dépôt de bilan et la nomination d'un
chargé de mission n'a pas calmé les
esprits jacques devaux gabriel kenya ça
fait maintenant trois jours que les
agriculteurs pour le siège de la
préfecture des côtes d'armor
les accès à la place sont barrées par
des camions un feu est régulièrement
entretenu par un impressionnant tas de
palettes cette nuit la tension est
montée d'un cran forces de l'ordre et
paysans se sont affrontés plusieurs
heures les nerfs sont à vif en
production avicole et porcine le tiers
des éleveurs seraient au bord du dépôt
de bilan
est ce que les gens peuvent comprendre
que se lever le matin et il perd de
l'argent en travaillant
est ce que c'est possible est ce que
parce que les conditions aux salariés
acceptaient de payer
n'ayez leurs salaires on allait
travailler le matin le premier chez nous
pour tenter de ramener le calme en
bretagne le gouvernement a nommé un
chargé de mission jean pierre gérondeau
est chargé de prendre des mesures
d'urgence en faveur des éleveurs
d'une part c'est la prise en compte par
le gouvernement de la gravité de la
situation ici est de la nécessité de
faire quelque chose donc de mettre des
actions en place pour remédier à la
situation
d'autre part ça confirme quand même
largement nos craintes c'est à dire que
le gouvernement a décidé au moins sur
une cuillère je penserai les cultures de
mettre en place un plan de
restructuration qui aura des
conséquences importantes je le crains en
termes d'emplois au niveau des
exploitations chez les éleveurs qui ont
déployé et aussi au niveau des salariés
dans les abattoirs les fabrique
d'aliment
en tout cas le blocus continue jusqu'à
demain le monde agricole viendra
manifester en famille pour réclamer des
mesures d'urgence
la grève des bus poursuit dans plusieurs
grandes villes de france de nombreuses
perturbations à nancy à metz mais aussi
à bordeaux ou encore à toulouse à
toulouse
aucun bus n'a circulé aujourd'hui les
salariés protestent contre la
modification d'un texte qui réglemente
leur profession depuis plus de 50 ans en
espagne après l'expiration cette nuit de
la trêve annoncée par le thé à nouvelle
manifestation pour refuser le retour à
la violence
l'union sacrée aux côtés des formations
politiques avec la présence pour la
première fois des indépendantistes déry
batasuna considéré comme la vitrine
légale de letea les milliers de
personnes se sont rassemblées devant les
mairies les édifices publics de la
plupart des villes basques quelques
incidents signalés à san sebastien des
jeunes séparatistes aux radicaux ont
empêché le déroulement de manifestations
étudiantes contre la rupture de la trêve
par ailleurs deux alertes à la bombe
dans des bâtiments administratifs
l'espagne redoute de nouveaux attentats
brève échéance les forces de sécurité
s'en placée en alerte maximale
et puis émotion est remué à une petite
ville industrielle du pays basque où
avait été assassiné il ya plus de deux
ans un jeune conseiller municipal du
parti populaire au pouvoir à l'époque
son meurtre avait suscité une immense
mobilisation aujourd'hui la population
est à nouveau descendue dans la rue
comme en témoigne le reportage de
dorothée olliéric et patrick voix
le cri qui l'oppose aux terroristes
c'est un silence de cinq longues minutes
parce que le thé à joues avec leur vie
et leur peur parce que le thé à a
assassiné en près de 40 ans 800
personnes ils sont là une fois encore
dans la rue depuis ce matin chacun se
demande où et quand le thé a va passer à
l'acte
la protestation s'achève comme toujours
au pays basque sur des applaudissements
quand j'entends ces applaudissements
cela me rappelle toutes les autres fois
toute la violence que je vous les auriez
et qui pourtant me colle à la peau c'est
terrible de revivre salle c'est la
première fois que les militants déry
batasuna le bras politique de letea se
joignent à une telle manifestation
comme les autres ils disent non à la
violence magnifique qu'ils ont compris
que la lutte armée ne mène nulle part et
qu'il y à d'autres façons de régler les
problèmes
bien sûr ils ont toujours leurs
revendications nationalistes mais au
moins c'est un petit pas en avant et
j'espère même un grand pas la petite
ville bernois est encore plein de
cicatrices de souffrance elle rêve
d'oublier un jour le sang qui a pu lys
et de la trêve à la guerre de la guerre
à la trêve herbeux à pleure toujours ses
morts il est des innocents que l'on
n'oublie pas tous pensent aujourd'hui à
miguel angel blanco assassiné en juillet
97 par le thé à miguel n'avait pas 30
ans il était l'enfant du pays sa mort
avait bouleversé toute l'espagne
plusieurs millions de personnes étaient
descendues dans les rues pour protester
pour dire non au terrorisme
aujourd'hui la peur est de retour au
pays basque en autriche sa vie lenzburg
après l'explosion d'un immeuble qui
s'est effondré hier soir une sixième
personne n'a été dégagé des décombres
trois autres sont toujours disparues les
sauveteurs continuent leur travail et
semble détecter d'autres survivants la
belgique se prépare au dernier grand
mariage du siècle ces deux mc le prince
héritier philippe de belgique épousera
une jeune aristocrate de 26 ans toutes
les têtes couronnées sont attendus pour
l'événement un mariage qui pourrait
redorer le blason d'un pays secoué par
des crises successives ces dernières
années à new york dominique maes
depuis les funérailles du roi baudouin
jamais la cathédrale de bruxelles n'a
connu pareille effervescence
on avait dans notre passé très courte on
avait quelques problèmes dans la
belgique très couru la course l'un après
l'autre et maintenant on a de nouveau
quelque chose pour fêter c'est pas la
douleur maintenant vingt-cinq mille
fleurs blanches pour un événement
qualifié par la population
d'exceptionnel c'est ici que demain le
futur roi philippe doit prendre femme
c'est bien sûr le mariage d'un couple
évidemment un petit mystère d'amour
c'est ça qui est beau mais c'est aussi
un événement qui marque un peu
l'histoire de la belgique une histoire
d'amour avec la population aussi depuis
ses fiançailles label matilda coquilles
au coeur des belges une aristocrate de
bonne famille
elle restait les qualités d'une future
reine jolie proche du peuple et surtout
elle rapproche les deux communautés
jusqu'ici très divisée quel est le
premier qualifié pour les flamands parce
qu'elle est née en pays flamand est
adoptée par les ballons parce qu'elle
parle le français prend en premier lieu
donc elle est vraiment belle jeu c'était
du côté devant les médias l'atild
apparaît tendrement enlacé avec le
prince philip était jusqu'ici plutôt
effacé ses finances à il aurait révélé
le couple fait chavirer le coeur des
belges
et pourtant dans les rues peu de signes
annonçant l'événement à peine une photo
dans un magasin quelle que façon devant
l'hôtel de ville
tous saluent ce mariage il assure
l'avenir de la monarchie
imbert et pour voir ses filles dont
c'est notre futur roi ils se marient
demain ici le roi n'a aucun pouvoir et
pourtant il vient de réussir un tour de
force
rassembler au moins momentanément toute
la population est relégué au second plan
les affaires qui ont secoué le pays
affaire dutroux poulet à la dioxine les
belges ont retrouvé une vraie raisons
d'avoir le sourire un cours en guyane
lancement réussi de la fusée ariane 5
avec à son bord un passager hors du
commun puisqu'il s'agit d'un satellite
espion baptisé hélios il a été largué
dans l'espace après 18 minutes de vol
l'intérêt de ce satellite d'observation
militaire est de fournir à l'europe à
nice spatiale capable de faire parvenir
des photos d'une extrême précision
jusqu'à un mètre de distance
nouvel épisode de l'odyssée spatiale
avec l'arrivée sur mars de la sonde de
polars lander dans les minutes qui
viennent si tout va bien la nasa suit
avec une extrême attention à
l'atterrissage de cette sonde là
derrière la dernière ayant explosé avant
de toucher la planète rouge
l'objectif de cette nouvelle aventure
est de trouver des traces d'eau sur
cette planète année santé
c'est ici que le parcours de la sonde
doit se terminer sur le pôle sud de la
planète mars au bout de 757 millions de
km 2 minutes avant d'atterrir un
parachute freinera la sonde
puis ce sont des rétrofusées qui
permettront aux modules de se poser en
douceur
première mission de la sonde à peine
trois quarts d'heure après son arrivée
filmer cette zone polaire seconde
mission écouter un microphone devrons
nous permettre d'entendre pour la
première fois les vents violents sur ma
troisième mission la plus importante
raclée gratter le sol et faire chauffer
des échantillons recueillis dans des
petits fours laboratoire à la recherche
de traces d'eau et peut-être de traces
de vie on ne sait pas si la vie a existé
sur mars
on sait que l a peut être existé il faut
maintenant la trouver soit sous une
forme encore existantes même si c'est
très peu probable
parce que c'est probablement une vie qui
existait il ya deux ou trois milliards
d'années c'est ancien valet en témoigne
l'eau coulait à flot mais elle ne
subsisterait plus aujourd'hui qu'à
l'état gazeux ou solide dans un sol gelé
pour creuser sous sol mars pour
l'irlande heures sera assisté de deux
mini sont- elles viendront s'écraser en
chute libre le choc libérera une foreuse
qui s'enfoncera de mètres dans le sol
avant de prélever un échantillon et de
renvoyer immédiatement les analyses sur
terre si tout va bien les premiers
résultats pourraient être connus dès
cette nuit le coup d'envoi du téléthon
2002 puis cette fin de journée pour 30
heures sur france 2 une nouvelle fois la
générosité des français qui
participeront à cette 13e édition tout
faire pour permettre à la recherche
d'avancer de mieux traiter ces maladies
génétiques
ces dernières années de nouveaux progrès
concernant notamment la mucoviscidose
permettent à ces enfants qui en sont
atteints d'espérer je vous propose le
témoignage exemplaire d'élise un
témoignage qu'il est difficile d'oublier
10 à 14 ans voici ce qu'elle a envie de
nous dire il forme à dire
ils savent à tes pas encore morte ça
partait pas de mauvais sentiments
c'était m6 imagine tout de suite que
j'allais mourir d'un quart d'heure à
l'autre et ça ne s'est pas un facteur
il avait 18 mois quand on vois pas
pourquoi ça alors là ça a été un
diagnostic très dur et on nous a dit
votre notre enfant est atteint de
mucoviscidose son espoir de vieille de
huit ans donc les rennais j'étais fou
puisqu'il est presque 14 ans et donc à
te feras mourou compressé commence à
faire monter les tensions c'est comme ça
c'est le problème dans la microfinance
c'est qu'il faut toujours toujours
toujours faut faire ces soins sans arrêt
ça sans s'arrêter et jours fériés les
vacances n'hésitez pas un problème coin
parce que je veux dire quand je fais des
familles soit trois candidats inscrits
clou d'un délit avec monthey qui gèle on
est soi-même tout doux
non non je prends une moi j'ai dit
souvent jeudi même si c'est pas moi qui
en profite
avec tout ce que j'ai fait et j'espère
qu'un jour il y en a qui en profiteront
et cela arrangera la vie donc en fait je
pars du principe on m'a déjà dit oui
nous toi peut-être que comme on trouvera
t'il sera bien morte elle a peut-être
mais en tout cas il y en aura d'autres
qui arriveront et qui pourront être
soignés ça c'est super ce portage est
signée nils tavernier nous retrouvons en
direct de montpellier jane birkin et
pierre perret bonsoir à tous les deux
cette année le téléthon a décidé
d'associer des comédiens et des
réalisateurs et vous de jane birkin
comme patrice leconte ou encore mireille
darc la cette question et à jane birkin
vous vous êtes rendu auprès des enfants
malades je voulais poser une question à
jean puisque le reportage dessiné nils
tavernier que jane birkin et ce quel
montant non vous m'entendez dizaine pour
quelles raisons vous avez eu envie de
passer derrière la caméra et de
recueillir des témoignages
parce que
caroline glorion m'avait demandé de
choisir entre deux professeurs entre le
professeur fisher et le professeur
munnich et de de les suivre toute la
journée à l'hôpital des enfants malades
à necker et quand je suis allé pour
leurrer parages comme on dit pour voir
leur travail parce que j'ai dit une
novice donc dans cette affaire j'ai été
séduite pas eu deux je ne pouvais pas
choisir
donc j'ai fait deux reportages sur le
professeur fisher et l'autre sur le
professeur munnich parce que pour moi il
était ils étaient des personnes donnent
d'une très haute charme
je parle de leur charme parce que les
personnes qui travaillent pour les
autres de 9 heures du matin et congés 19
7h30 du matin jusqu'au 10 heures du soir
et après ça qui de vous leur vie aux
autres
il dégage une très grand chat mais une
très grande humilité devant le maladie d
autres devant le désarroi des autres et
devant leur propre aux possibilités et
leurs propres découvertes alors je
restais g rester devant cette cette
humanité qui était représenté pour moi
ces jours-là passé deux hommes vous en
parlait très bien et jane birkin dans un
instant nous retrouverons pierre perret
je voudrais d'abord préciser que ce
matin lionel jospin a annoncé que la
france allait débloquer un milliard de
francs supplémentaires sur cinq ans à
partir de l'an prochain pour la
recherche sur le génome humain
le premier ministre qui visitait le
genopole d'evry a voulu témoigner du
soutien du gouvernement qui a précisé
que cette somme serait affecté à un
nouveau réseau associant laboratoires
publics et entreprises privées
ils n'agissent pas qui va prendre sa
part à ce treizième téléthon comme bien
d'autres familles en france est il
précisé alors de nombreuses
manifestations 22000 au total sont
prévus dans toute la france une nouvelle
fois en fait appel à la solidarité des
français
il faut bien comprendre que les sommes
allouées par le gouvernement ce matin ne
doivent pas diminuer la générosité du
public
l'affectation de ces différents
financements l'un public l'autre fait de
vos dons est essentiel très direction
antenne 2 organise le premier téléthon
en 1987 une formule inédite en france
importé des états unis grâce à bernard
barataud le président de l'association
française contre les myopathies au
compteur cette année-là 195 millions de
francs de dos et ce n'était qu'un début
douze ans plus tard la somme totale
récoltée approchera les 5 milliards une
somme qui a notamment permis la
construction du généthon un laboratoire
unique au monde
à l'origine de la première carte du
génome humain depuis la fm assure seul
l'essentiel de la recherche française
l'état lui est en retard un retard qu'il
cherche aujourd'hui à combler en
développement 1 milliard très attendu ça
fait belle lurette que on a parlé dans
des discours que la biologie devait être
une priorité clamer la recherche
médicale doivent être une priorité mais
ça n'était pas vrai on gardait des
budgets qui étaient modestes pour la
biologie mais ce milliard financera
exclusivement la recherche publique et
non les activités de l'afm l'association
a maintenant ses propres objectifs et
elle a toujours besoin de la générosité
publique
mon dieu si jamais ça remplace l argent
du téléthon je disposais arrêtez tout de
suite mais ça ne le remplace pas ne
l'état a tellement de choses en retard à
combler que je comprends très bien
qu'ils investissent dans ces dons tout
ce secteur là mais nous on est ailleurs
on nous sommes dans encore plus loin
dans les hypothèses de thérapie c'est à
dire de traitement de médicaments pour
la première fois la fm vient d'ailleurs
d'obtenir l'autorisation de procéder à
un essai de thérapie génique
une raison de plus pour répondre plus
généreusement encore que d'habitude aux
appels du téléthon 1999 et donc en
direct de montpellier nous retrouvons le
parrain de cette et les tendons téléthon
2000 pierre perret bonsoir c'est tout un
programme avec ses formidables
perspectives de la médecine génétique du
21ème siècle
oui ça me fait plaisir je suis vraiment
honoré d'être parent pour la deuxième
fois
je pense qu'il ya certainement beaucoup
d'autres qui auraient pu s'investir à ma
place parce que bon départ 1 il y en a
plein qui sont prêts à partir au starter
pour la bonne cause
mais moi j'avais fait des promesses il
ya cinq ans quand j'ai déjà été parrains
j'avais promis de suivre tout ce qui se
passe on m'avait promis que justement
l'avancée des recherches seraient
considérables à partir de tout ce qu'on
pourrait récolter et dieu sait s'il y en
a qui se sont investis là dedans
tiana qui dans l'ombre qui justement
comme disait jane tout à leur travail ce
qu'on connaît pas qui sacrifie quasiment
leur vie leur temps d'être à leurs côtés
c'est un honneur je trouve ça
extraordinaire que chaque année est de
plus en plus de gens qui s'investissent
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure à
propos de lionel jospin du gouvernement
qui met pour une fois des sommes aussi
considérable parce que c'est vraiment un
beau geste qu'il a fait là on en
attendait pas moins d'eux mais que ça
n'empêche pas tous ceux qui sont autour
de nous la dans tous les pays dans toute
la france même les pays étrangers qui se
sont investis cette année tous les pays
côtiers la suisse la belgique l'italie
etc qui sont dans le coup aussi
c'est quelque chose de merveilleux parce
qu'en france à marseille à nantes
partout il ya des centres qui s'ouvrent
les recherches avancent et bon moi je
dis ô les choeurs faut pas s'arrêter là
parce que on va aller beaucoup plus loin
c'est sûr j'espère et et haut les coeurs
pour toute cette soirée nous vous
retrouvons tout de suite après le
journal hamon encore pour évoquer
maintenant la fondation hôpitaux de
paris hôpitaux de france bernadette
chirac qui en est la présidente annoncé
que l'opération donnant des couleurs à
l'hôpital a recueilli 4 millions de
français dont doivent permettre
d'améliorer la qualité de vie de
quelques cent mille personnes âgées
hospitalisées
l'événement sportif avec la coupe davis
à nice le premier point a été remporté
en début d'après-midi par l'australie
avec la victoire de mark philippoussis
ce qui a battu sébastien grosjean 6-4
6-2 6-4
cédric pioline le numéro un tricolore
vient d'égaliser pour la france en
battant le jeune australien lleyton
hewitt
christelle bertrand
ipou 6 a dominé sébastien grosjean de la
tête et des épaules
moins de deux heures de match sur le
court sébastien est l'invité de marque
pour une leçon de tennis
l'australien en excès de vitesse est
pressé d'en finir
grosjean crispé a quand même réussi
quelques coups magiques
mais le colosse australien avance et
prendre l'avancé au score 6 4 6 2 au
troisième set philippot 6 continue sur
sa lancée 6 jeux à 4
facilement l'australie mène 1 0
branges ans a été dépassé par les
événements mais comme il jouait très
bien mais j'avais des otages les saisies
c'est pas très bien je t'entends de
mauvais choix et lui lui à chaque fois
il avait un petit peu de réussite pour
provoquer pour bien jouer
mark philippoussis ce a su saisir sa
chance
le kangourou australien s'est bien faire
le coq mais le chef de la basse cour a
remis les pendules à l'heure cédric
pioline est allé jusqu'au bout du score
dans les deux premiers sets le français
mène 2-0
la tension monte
lleyton hewitt n'a pas failli à sa
réputation il s'est battu jusqu'au bout
cédric pioline en vieux briscard a fait
parler l'expérience
il vient chercher les points à la volée
le français sans trembler a mis un terme
au suspense au bout de trois heures et
demie 7 6 7 6 7 5
le numéro un de l'équipe redonne de
l'espoir au plan français un point
partout demain le double ne va pas être
simple non plus l'américaine victoria me
redonne n'est devenue la première femme
à réussir la traversée de l'atlantique à
la rame elle est arrivée aujourd'hui à
la guadeloupe
partis le 13 septembre des canaries la
navigatrice surnommée tori âgé de 36 ans
a été accueilli par gérard d'aboville
qui était lui le premier homme à avoir
réussi une traversée de l'atlantique en
solitaire d'ouest en est ouest doit
d'est en ouest puis c'était en 1981
barry white en concert à bercy lundi
depuis plusieurs semaines plus aucune
place à vendre il faut dire que barry
white a réalisé une année 99
exceptionnel olivier les mutins gilbert
usant le silence
et puis comme par enchantement la voie
choisie par les dieux pour célébrer
l'amour
on peut
début 70 barry white signe son premier
tube avec le trio féminin la vallée
mittal trente ans plus tard le prince de
la soul a vendu plus de 100 millions
d'albums composé des dizaines de
chansons dont le seul thème ressemble un
je t'aime sec j'ai le trac avant de
monter sur scène du génie sorti des
bas-fonds d'un ghetto de los angeles est
aujourd'hui célébrée par les plus grands
mais également par la nouvelle
génération à l'image des fun lovin
criminals le groupe new yorkais qui rend
hommage à une voix ou combien profonde
et sensuelle
pas mal
je vais bien
m'a plu
barry white a su inventer un style
charnelle des chansons qui ressemblent à
des ballades langoureuses susurré par le
baryton de l'amour
ainsi se termine ce journal vous se
rappellent les deux principaux titres a
situé à seattle situation de crise à
quelques heures de la clôture de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
difficiles négociations de nombreuses
divergences entre l'union européenne et
les etats-unis notamment finale de la
coupe davis à nice depuis cet après midi
mark philippoussis s'est offert le
premier point à l'australie cédric
pioline vient de gagner face à lleyton
hewitt 7 et permet à la france
d'égaliser dans un instant la météo
valérie alexandre puis le point route
valérie maurice je vous laisse
évidemment compagnie du téléthon avec
tous ces animateurs pierre perret sophie
davant patrick sienne et tant d'autres
merci de votre attention excellente fin
de soirée sur france 2